The UK and the European Union wrangled for
months over a deal that was supposed to
regulate their post-Brexit trade relationship.
But almost a year after it went into force,
the squabbling continues. French fishermen say
London's not honoring its side of the bargain
by refusing to grant access to its waters -
and now Paris is threatening to take action.
The Jeremy-Florent is returning to harbor after
a night out in the Channel - it
has not been a successful trip.
"The whole catch: There are about 20 kg of Dover
sole back there, and all these are dogfish;
they don't really sell; they're worth
no more than 20 to 50 cents per kilo,
so it's nothing, and a few crabs. All this
stuff in the nets it's worth nothing."
The one box of good fish won't even
cover the costs of the boat's fuel.
Back at sea, Christophe shows us how limited
his fishing grounds have become since Brexit:
"This whole part there - we can't work anymore,
all that is left is this small bit here where we
can work. It's nothing, only half is left. This
whole zone where we worked before we don't have
access to. And the British - they'll pursue us if
we enter their waters. I don't have a license."
He's not the only one.
47 small boats applied
to keep fishing in UK waters post-Brexit,
but the UK side granted just 12 licenses.
"Here it's really a total loss. Since January
the small boats haven’t been allowed to enter
Britain's 12 mile zone. We accuse them of not
respecting the agreement they signed, which says
access to the waters should be preserved. And
now they've added many criteria to block people."
Paris has promised to fight back.
"The British side today obviously does not
want to respect the agreement as it was signed.
There is now a great effort from the French side
with the EU Commission to move forward quickly
on this issue that has gone on for too long."
Here at Boulogne's fish market where the daily
catch is sold, families are feeling the squeeze:
"The ships can't go there any
more, it creates problems.
Less fishing, less fish, less money, less sales."
"We have less flat fish, things like plaice
and Dover sole are difficult to get. It's a
catastrophe. With Brexit we can't go where we
did before, so we catch less fish. Last week
we had hoped we would get a license, but no. I
don't know what we'll do. Maybe go on strike?"
Some fishermen here have even threatened to block
the Channel tunnel connecting France and Britain.
Jeremy Lhomel followed in his father's
footsteps in becoming a fisherman,
but now he fears the line stops here.
"I'm not working more than 6 months per year,
this can't go on, it's over. Now the season
for the whelks is beginning, and they live
in British waters and we can't go there.
But hope keeps us alive; we're waiting
another week for news from our government.
We'll see."
Batisse
is the traditional symbol of
Boulogne's fishermen – the
future he's looking out on has
never seemed more uncertain.